Robert is with us in Chicago hey Robert
how are you good thank you for taking my
call
sure what's up so my sister is 28 years
old and she has $10,000 in car loans and
40,000 in private student loans and this
will be the fourth month that she has
not paid for those loans and my mom is
65 retired with government pension and
Social Security Social Security
she is the cosigner so she did get a
formal warning from the collectors about
the submitting her to the credit bureau
and try and scare so my question is can
her wages be garnished no but they can
be her government and her social can be
deducted for the student loans but they
can't be garnished on the car that's not
technically a garnishment it's just it
is a garnishment so it works but yeah
the student loans can get her but get to
her but the car can't get to her now if
she owns anything else if she has money
in a bank account somewhere they could
get that yeah she has a traditional IRA
with and get the hello Bernie I can't
get that but if she has a bank account
with $10,000 in it just sitting there
mm-hmm they could just grab that after
they sued you in one so how much my mom
got in her IRA 90 mm and what's sisters
problem she loves to take on debt and
never pay it back but I'm saying why is
she why was she paying up until four
months ago and now she's not
I guess she just couldn't find any
crying we're not too sure she Blin tell
us why she couldn't pay okay so she's
dumping it on her mom who's retired and
on a fixed income and doesn't hardly
have any money
exactly what a winner unfortunately
there's one in every fan my brother oh
my gosh oh my gosh so mom is alive mom
is liable okay
she's signed the note that's what
co-signing is that's why co-signing
stupid and so have they picked up the
car not yet but they are threatening
agrees the repossession of the car I
believe she has one more month before
that
oh no it's four months they can get it
now I would I would tell mom to call
them since she's on the account and tell
them to come get the car
what let's shake sister's tree a little
hey get her car out of the driveway I
bet you find some clients yeah and then
you can help mom work to settle the debt
on the repo and mom's credit is gonna be
messed up but it was messed up when
there was four payments not made yeah
don't come get the car let's see if we
can get this thing moving yeah Dave's in
a mean mood this is the Dave Ramsey show